[Music]
hello youtube just loves my friends this
is gunjin here
welcome to my 65th episode of dirty jazz
tricks
in this episode i'm going to show you a
wonderful
high profile trick in the bishop d2
scandinavian variation
from the white perspective the critical
position arises
after the following opening more order
e4 d5 e catches d5
queen captures d5 knight to c3
queen to e5 and now white follow the
main line for a while
d4 knight to f6
and now there are two options white can
choose
but i like this straightforward one
namely bishop to d2
so planning is very obvious that white
is
all set to get a discovery on the black
queen
and accordingly black has tried two
responses
well if you open and continue with c6
then i think this is a big time
inaccuracy
as now the purpose of bishop to d2 can
be revealed
immediately with this fantastic move
knight to e4 attacking the queen
and it doesn't matter wherever the queen
goes
let's say queen to c7 we can chop up
this knight
and after any pawn recapture he captures
f6
you can see the point behind this whole
transaction
not only black get this horrible double
pawn on the king side
and generally white has to surrender the
bishop pair
in order to achieve it but here
he get free of cost which give him
the early advantage in the opening stage
so that is the reason why here
c6 is inaccurate move
and as per the theory many books and
videos
have recommended the moon bishop to g4
which is known as complete remedy
of this bishop to d2 line
the idea is very obvious that if white
continue with
knight to f3 then black get huge
pressure
on this d4 pawn with knight to c6
and if you play bishop to e2 then black
is happily exchanges bad bishop
with our good bishop and resulting
positions
are quite balanced for the black camp
so in a nutshell white is forced to play
the move
f3 attacking the bishop and after bishop
to f5
you can see what black has achieved is
he has provoked some weaknesses on the
white king side
and all set to continue with his usual
scandinavian setup
starting with e6 and c6
well that's a great news except
one problem that white has a nasty
modern trick up in his sleeve and the
tricky business start with this
very cunning water bishop to c4
encouraging black to continue his setup
let's say c6 first and after knight g to
e2
black plays the obvious scandinavian
move e6
getting his familiar pawn due
where bishop is outside the pawn chain
but the matter of fact is after this
he is completely lost
yup you heard it right and this is the
beauty about this modern tricks
so before i move on guys i want you to
pause this video
and find out a sequence where
by force white get a completely
upper hand
are you ready let's start the first move
is
very obvious g4 attacking the bishop
this bishop doesn't have any space
except
bishop to g6 and now no prize for
guessing white's next reply
yup you got it h4
trying to trapping down that bishop and
accordingly
either black has to move the edge pawn
or as happened in one of the game from
the database
a nearly 2300 rated opponent
continue with queen to b4
a counter attack to the white bishop
okay white plays bishop to b3
saving the bishop and now threatening h5
something which black has to respond
immediately
and in fact he did with the move h5
only to feel the root shock
bam
so suddenly that queen has been trapped
down
well black can't play queen to b5 as
knight to c7 chad
will nap the black sweetie so that is
right out of the equation and the only
move
queen to d6 fails immediately as after
white's next reply
bishop to f4 black simply
resigned the game as wherever the queen
moves
let's say queen to d8 we have this
juicy folk which not only grab the rook
in the corner
but on top of everything black king
has been completely misplaced
so what a miniature guys just 15 move
and
2300 rated opponent crossed
so it is now pretty clear that queen to
b4 is a great time
inaccuracy so accordingly black has to
save the bishop
by moving dutch pawn and no matter
whether he played h6 or h5 most frequent
choices
at 6 our response will be very
consistent
knight to f4 so now the threat is
knight captures g6 and then capture on
e6
so black shouldn't allow this and
accordingly
bishop to h7 is the only reply
but after white's next killing move
queen to e2
no matter however black plays he is
on the verge of losing the game
well it sounds strange and at first
sight it doesn't look like
but believe me if you put this position
in any chess
engine it will give us white a plus two
advantage the more you look at this
position
more you will understand that white has
a very simple thread
namely g5 and then some sacrifice on e6
which is very very difficult for black
cam
to defend just for your information
there are more than 15 2000 plus rated
opponent
fallen into this line and lost the game
pretty quickly
well to illustrate my point i like to
show you two quick
wins by wide in the first game
black continue with bishop to b4
but white response cannot be denied
yup g5 attacking the knight
h captures g5 and now very nice move
knight captures e6 not giving any
chance for the survival
well that night is too dangerous so
black should take it off
but after that the sequence is pretty
much forced
h captures g5 attacking the knight
knight to d5 and now the whole point
behind the sequence
g6 and look at that monster pawn
i think he deserved to become the next
queen
well the game finished very quickly
black played the moon
bishop captures c3 and after pawn
capture c3
he realized that if the king will remain
in the center
then game will not last long so he'd try
to reject the king
with knight to d7 but i'm afraid this is
very late
as after queen captures e6 king 2d8
white has a stunning reply g captures at
7
and black fined to his horror that the
plan he was aiming to do
rook to e8 completely fails due to the
simple tactic
queen captures eight king takes and
white promotes
donor the queen well black struggle on
for the few moves and you can check it
in the pgn
but at this point it is easy to say that
with the two bishop against two night
and two pawn advantage white is
in a completely driver's seat
last but not least the most frequent
choice here is
queen to c7 but against all of this
response
white has a pretty consistent threat yup
g5 h captures g5 and this time around
because the queen is controlling
the seventh rank white respond with the
move
h captures g5 well if the knight moves
then we will see the similar tactical
patent as we seen
in the earlier game so here black come
up
with this nice counter tactical move
bishop to d3 unleashing the attack
to the hvan rook as well as white queen
it may be sound surprising but this is
all been planned by the white cam
as he sacrifices queen with rook
captures h8
well now the sequence is pretty much
forced bishop captures e2
pawn takes f6 and now in the view of f
captures g7 thread
black has to respond with g captures f6
which allow white to regain another
piece
with knight captures e2 and
if you count the material at this point
white get three pieces
against queen and a pawn which is
generally
always turn out to be a good trade
here the bonus part is black king is
stuck in the center
and that was the critical factor which
closed the game
very quickly
knight to d7 happened white castles
and now black tried to generate some
counter play
with the move a5 trying to dislodge the
bishop
but only to get self shock
boom
what a move well
what's the point the idea is very
obvious
after f captures e6 and the moon knight
captures e6
not only white knight attacking the
queen
but this means that black king
will be permanently sit at the center
of the board queen to d6 happened
attacking the knight white first support
the knight
with knight to f4 and suddenly
black is literally running out of the
moose
well he tried the move b6 but this was
the last mistake
as after the following sequence knight
to g7 check
it doesn't matter whether king goes to
f7 or d8
both treated equally king to d8
and now knight to f5 attacking the queen
queen to be it happened completely tying
down the big pieces and here comes the
final deciding blow
knight to e6 jack king 28
knight captures f8 and here
black resigns in the view of very simple
sequence knight captures f8
rook to even check
you can't play king to f7 as after rook
to e7 check
king to g6 and knight to h4 we have a
picturesque checkmate
on the board so that is right
out of the equation and the other move
king to d7 doesn't escape the checkmate
sequence
as after rook to e7 check king to d8
and rook captures f8 black
certainly do not want to see this
position
on the board
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile trick in the bishop to d2
scandinavian
remember at this point shock your
opponent
with the move g4 as i have shown
in this video the sequence is pretty
much force
and when finally white play the move
queen to e2
it doesn't matter however black plays
white full quick point is awaiting on
the board
you can literally use this line as a
complete surprise weapon
in the tournament practice thank you for
watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you
in my next episode very soon bye
and take care